Let's see who wants to check in today.
Let's go to Chris from Texas.
Chris from Texas.
You were on.
What is on your mind today, my friend?
Hey, David.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you perfectly, all right.
I called you about a couple of months ago
and I wanted to say thank you for, like.
Teaching me how to think more critically,
like I remember saying how I could fight that
battle with other people, when you're looking
at the polls from 538.
It looks like it's pretty much over for Trump
at this point.
I mean, Biden would have to have to literally
about have to die in order for Trump to win
right now.
Well, listen, I hope that you are right, but
all we need to do is just vote, right.
We ultimately have no control over anything
other than whether we vote.
So I love the optimism.
The polls look ugly right now, but we just
don't know.
In the 25 days that are left, we just don't
know.
So I share your cautious optimism.
Let's focus on the cautious and let's make
sure we vote.
Yeah, I understand.
I'm going to vote.
I'm going to vote next week.
Tuesday as well.
Beautiful.
Also.
So also wondering to now, like with two of
the Senate members testing positive different
Corona virus, three, in fact.
Oh, three three now.
Yeah, well, it's it's Mike Lee.
Thom Tillis and Ron Johnson.
Yeah.
So you think it's possible that Amy Coheed.
How you pronounce your name.
Amy CONI Barret's nomination will be the lead
now.
I do think that there is a good chance that
it doesn't happen before Election Day.
But if Republicans are determined, I don't
see any way that it won't happen during the
period between the election and the inauguration.
My only hope is if the corona virus positives
prevent the vote from happening before November
3rd and then Joe Biden wins and Democrats
take the Senate and the Martha McSally seat
is immediately seated because remember, that's
a special election.
So, Mark, if Mark Kelly wins, he might be
seated right away.
I'm hoping that there would be such outrage
if Republicans still try to push it through.
I'm talking outrage to the point of mass rallies,
and I don't know if that will happen.
That would be the dream scenario that Republicans
abandon the nomination.
It's very optimistic.
It's very uphill.
But I think it's the only chance we've got.
Also, I'm kind of worried about packing the
courts as well.
I thought, I know people say that they want
to pack the courts just because they want
to at least be able to get progressive reform.
Yeah.
But I'm worried that it could be used against
us in the future for Republicans to pack the
court as well.
It certainly could.
But here's the here's what I would say.
Here's what I would say to that, Chris.
Joe Biden has has not answered whether he
would or wouldn't be in favor of that.
And I think he's been smart not to answer
it for now because it would.
Whatever he answers will become the focus.
And it's not really what this is about.
If you look back at Joe Biden's history, my
reading of it is that he is unlikely to pack
the court.
So I actually if you're concerned about that,
I don't actually think Biden will do it.
Okay.
My last question is, what do you think we
should do if Joe Biden becomes president?
Shall we try to push for more leftwing policies
or should we just try to undo all of the damage
Trump has done first?
Well, it's both.
It's not one or the other.
I mean, a lot of the damage Trump has done
can be undone via executive orders that give
orders.
And at the same time, particularly if Democrats
take the Senate, then you've got big legislative
accomplishments that we can start working
on.
So you've got to do both.
Yes.
All right.
Thank you for the time, David.
Chris, I appreciate it so much.
Chris from Texas.
Great to hear from Chris from Texas.